hey this is Moshe kasher and Natasha
Leggero we just got married six months
ago which we think pretty much makes us
qualified to give love advice to
strangers so that's what we did we
packed up the car hit the road and
spread the love
yes is the honeymoon tour are you
feeling yeah for every show I like these
scoops I did jump bus dude I couldn't
get away to the nap huh a little bit
like fat-shaming
but it was about a woman that I once saw
in an airport and she had a she had a
king-size snicker bar ice cream she was
scooping out the ice cream with these
Tostitos scoops oh there's nothing
that's gonna I'm eating it like a ball
boy do you can't do a joke like that cuz
it's about shaming um I mean I could do
the joke but it might not work putting
that funny
washing it down with a with a king size
though double tall redbull I was like
you want to be awake for this I have a
real real real question
not a short one not a joke one way but
hold on this is he are you in a
relationship okay we got a single all
right hold on okay what's your name is
that your player very can both of you
thank you but my question is why do
women love assholes like you mean why do
women love jerks yeah like it I don't
know like I try to be nice cool but it's
like every single time it just doesn't
work out okay how old are you I'm 19 19
how did you build Ryu and you're 19
so here's trying to understand you're
basically saying that you're the youth
that you feel like the women that you go
after cuz you're a nice guy like mean
people but maybe it's just that you
haven't found the right person yet it's
not about women it's just about the
people that you've met so we can't make
jokes about fat which I understand what
else rapes not funny anymore
I know sucks it sucks that we live in
them in a world where rapes no longer
hilarious I'm going use down rape joke
now you can't do them I think you should
do rape jokes
they don't come to me cuz you're scared
of the back-left um I want to just
become more sensitive about it
including me well no I'm just saying no
I'm just saying sensitive about joking
about it
roars comedies you know you just you try
to diffuse terrible situations by making
jokes about it absurd stuff you know
it's not like I think rape is not
horrible of course it's horrible for
eight years my strongest joke was
probably a rape joke for five years what
is it one time I need this girl and she
was like this is a good joke I know this
one you see is he never been raped
before
no why you never woke up in a potty and
some guy was inside you I never woke up
in a party
hahaha she's it also I would like to add
that you know I kind of liked assholes
till I was like 30 so it's going to take
a little bit of time to meet someone you
might have to grow up a little bit you
know
like deal with some women what are you
looking for in a woman I'm just gonna
I got a question why are women these
trifling ass women all they want is some
man that will use them abusing them
bounce these I'm trying to them and
leave but it's a different okay
okay
repent please explain yours okay so I
just feel like you should I don't feel
like for me like I'm not it's cool if
you want to like you know hook up with
people and you don't like if you want to
like how like one-night stands like
that's fine but like for me I just feel
like you should get to know someone
first like you know stable they're cool
and like you see if you have that
relationship then you know that can
carry on to sex but it doesn't have to
be like I have this look neither
solution I hold on Dan I got I got I
know what you need to do exactly you
littered and literally you can't not do
it you need to be 11 years older than
you are right now I do sleep with three
chihuahuas yeah I do
don't hug me I like dogs I'm not your
ally here I'm an opposite I'm anal I I'm
like anal whatever the opposite is